là c'est moi franck amaury aujourd'hui
c'est mon anniversaire mais mon patron
m'a demandé un service et j'ai pas pu
dire oui bonjour je viens pour le buggy
steam alors voici donc ce salon le matin
rémy prend du nesquik de la brioche et
unitel sam raimi ça se passait pas si
mal mais un détail près pouvoir et oui
ce soir est un grand soir puisque nous
sommes venus souhaiter un joyeux
anniversaire à l'autre c'est quoi ça un
somnifère
j'étais complètement taré temps j'espère
que ça va bien se passer là il en a
jusqu'à demain t'inquiète je connais
bien sûr tu curieux et loppsi la
disparue rémy ceux qui appuyaient ont
par le chercher est ce que c'est vous
pouvez en attendant nous parlons bien
tout le monde aucun problème franck
passe aussi qu'on gère
jérôme
et ça c'était une idée
on avait conclu jeu
pourquoi
franchement je crois pas que ce soit
vraiment chose désolée